[MUSIC]
You may be surprised but the most popular
algorithms for finding motifs in DNA
sequences, roll dice
and take chances to find such motifs.
They're called randomized algorithms.
How do they work?
We have now learned how to construct Profile
given
Motifs, but can we construct Motifs given
Profile?
We can, because given an arbitrary Profile
and a set of sequences Dna,
we can construct the set Motifs(Profile,DNA)
by simply finding
Profile-most probable k-mers in each
sequence from Dna.
And therefore, we can further iterate this
process by finding profile of motifs,
motifs of profiles, profile of motifs,
until our motifs keep improving.
So this is the key idea of the algorithm
called RandomizedMotifSearch.
We simply iterate and see whether the
score of motif continues
to improve. And stop when it doesn't
improve anymore.
The only question about this
algorithm is
how in the world it can find anything
useful.
Think about this, we started from
a completely random motifs.
If the motifs are completely random,
and if they're taken from random
sequences,
then presumably. expected probability of
every element
in the profile matrix is 1/4.
There is absolutely no information in such
a motif.
How possibly it can lead us to the correct
motif in the sequence?
Let's just keep our fingers crossed and
see how this approach works on an example.
Here's my example.
These are very short DNA strings and I
implanted
4-nucleotide long motifs (one motif on each string).
They're shown in blue, so
ACGT is implanted in every sequence with a
single mutation.
So how randomized motif search will
proceed?
First, it will randomly select motifs
shown in bold here.
And, of course, it has missed most
of the motifs.
They are randomly selected.
Afterwards, it will form Motifs matrix,
shown here on
the slide, and afterwards it will
construct Profile(Motifs).
Using Profile(Motifs) it will calculate
the probability
of every k-mer in the set of strings,
shown here, and will simply select the most
probable k-mers in every string.
The results are in this matrix, and I
should probably start iterating.
But if you look carefully at this matrix,
I don't have to iterate.
It already found all blue inserted motifs
right there.
It almost sounds like a magic
trick, because we started from something
completely random
and, in a single iteration, found our
implanted motifs!
Well, what happened?
So let's try to think about this.
When we form k-mers randomly, it results
in a uniform expected profile,
as we discussed before.
But strings in Dna are not random
because w have inserted implanted
patterns
in our Dna strings.
Therefore,  this implanted motif
resulted in a biased profile;
it's not a completely random profile.
Where does this statistical bias point to?
If it points
in the direction of the implanted motif, then
there is no miracle
that we start from something random (which
is not really random),
and, applying iterative procedure, arrived to a
hidden part.
So, let's see how it actually works.
I return back to the case that we
considered before.
You saw that when we randomly selected
motifs, in the first sequence, we missed
the motif (the correct, the blue one).
In the second sequence, we also missed it.
In the third sequnce, we missed it.
In the fourth sequence, we missed it.
But in the fifth one, simply by pure
chance, we actually found it.
It's not a big deal.
There is always a probability that we
simply by chance
select one of the implanted motifs.
But it results in a biased profile.
If you look at the profiles that
resulted from this implantation, then you
see that the largest elements
in this profile actually correspond to
A, C, G and T
of our implanted pattern ACGT.
Therefore, even
a single correctly found k-mer in
the set of Dna strings creates a bias in
the profile, and this bias
leads us to the correct sequence.
Of course, it doesn't always happen.
It depends on how we have chosen initial
set of randomly selected k-mers in the
sequence.
But if we try this algorithm, a thousand
or
a million times, there is a good chance
that
eventually one of these attempts will
bring us to
the correct motif. Even if this procedure
sounds ridiculous.
We now move to the next topic:
"How do bacteria hibernate?"
Our goal is to apply our motifs finding algorithm
to real biological problems.
To figure out how our algorithms work on
real biological data, we will start by
analyzing tuberculosis.
Tuberculosis is a deadly disease that
killed quarter of population of Europe in
the 19th century.
Unfortunately, humanity is not done
with tuberculosis yet since
tuberculosis strains that resist
to all antibiotics are now emerging.
Tuberculosis is caused by
Mycobacterium tuberculosis also called
MTB.
An interesting thing about MTB
is that it can persist in for decades in humans
and one third of the world population is
affected by MTB.
Of course, it usually doesn't lead to
tuberculosis
nut, in some cases. bacteria switches
from its latent
state to the active state and
it's when the tuberculosis begins.
The question that we will be asking is how
MTB switches from the latent to the active state
and how
does it survive during latency?
MTB has an ability
to form dormant spores where metabolism is
shut down.
In such sporulated form it can survive
in
very tough conditions, for example, in
conditions of food shortage or
oxygen shortage.
And oxygen shortage, called hypoxia, is
associated with these latent forms of
tuberculosis.
So, how can we figure out what makes
MTB switch into the latent state and
return back to
the active states?
Biologists have performed a
DNA array experiment and identified
roughly 25 genes that are activated in the
hypoxic condition.
So when bacteria is deprived from
oxygen, these gene dramatically change
their expression.
And our goal today is to discover what
regulatory
motif controls these genes when they're
activated or repressed.
We now have quite an arsenal of algorithms
for finding motifs.
Let's try them.
But the first problem is that we have
no clue of what size of motif to try.
Should we try k equal to 8 or k equal to 20?
Let's try all of them
using median string problem and randomized
motif search.
And you will see that, for different k,
we are getting quite different results.
It is not clear which one to choose.
for median string, we actually will have
difficulties going beyond k=12
because
it is an exponential algorithm whose
running time grows as four to the power k.
But for randomized motif search we can
search
for very long motif and, for k=20,
we actually find this rather long
motif.
You can see that there are
similarities
Between the 12-mer found by the Median String.
the 12-mer found by the RandomizedMotifSearch,
and the 20-mer found by the RandomizedMotifSearch.
Which one is correct?
To answer this
question, we need to introduce the notion
of the motif entropy.
And entropy of motif is defined in the
following way.
First, we construct the profile matrix.
Every column of the profile matrix correspond
to a biased four-sided dice.
Or, in other words, to a probability
distribution, (p1, p2, ...p_n).
Sum of p_i is equal
to 1, of course.
And entropy is simply defined as
- p_i * log (p_i)
and summed up over all indices i.
For example, we can compute the entropy of
the first column, and it will be 1.147.
We can compare it with the minimal
possible entropy, which corresponds to the
extremely conserved motif
(where all symbols in the column are the
same),
and with the maximal entropy
(where symbola in the column are equally likely).
So the entropy of a motif is defined as
the sum of the entropies of its columns.
And now, the moment of truth.
Let's see how the algorithms that we
developed
find out whether the motifs that we find
are close to the biological one.
Here is the motif logo of the dormancy
survival regulator site.
The motif logo is constructed in such a
way that the total length of four
nucleotides in the motif logo correspond
to two minus entropy.
So for completely conserved column, like
nucleotide G
in this motif, we will have height two.
It is the most conserved
columns of the motif.
The relative sizes of
four nucleotide in
each position correspond to frequencies of
these nucleotides in the column.
This is an example of
motif logo.
Now, let's see how it works for
the tuberculosis example.
You can see that our randomized motif
search has actually captured a good portion of
the motif.
But you can also see that we missed in
some places.
We need to work harder and to
figure
out what to do to develop better
regulatory motif finding algorithms.
We move next to another randomized
algorithm called Gibbs sampler.